new york post headline bye don
hello ron desantis pulls in millions
from former trump donors ahead of
november election if you read in the
column
it says a weekend politico analysis well
do you trust it i don't know of campaign
finance data found that at least 10
donors who spent 24 million dollars on
trump's re-election bid in 2020 have
since donated approximately 3.4 million
dollars to the republican governor's
political committee friends of ron
desantis well
ron desantis is running for reelection
so of course a lot of money is going to
be going there but that's not the point
pay attention media oh
maybe we can create a bigger rift here
oh maybe there's something going on here
maybe we could divide the right oh
don't take the bait
don't take the bait
another headline i was set to cover it
with just that article do a short rap
then i see this this morning
politico
shocking
2024 intrigue desantis declines to ask
trump for reelection endorsement here we
go
here we go they're having fun already
with you they're having fun they want to
puppeteer you
florida republic republican governor ron
desantis has plenty of advantages ahead
of his november re-election more than
100 million dollars in the bank
a growing statewide republican voter
advantage massive popularity with the
conservative base what desantis doesn't
need and isn't requesting former
president donald trump's endorsement do
you see what they're doing
keep your eyes open
don't take the bait they want you they
want the people who love desantis but
aren't that fond of trump to come out
and say oh desantis is the guy he saves
this guy trump stinks trump's got too
much baggage trump this trump they want
the people who love trump trump
loyalists out there to say well no it's
trump look what trump did last time
around look at the policies desantis is
new to santa's needs to stay in florida
they want that fight
they want that fight
they are going to eat this up the idea
now i don't know if there's a feud i
don't know behind the scenes if they
talk if they're friends i don't care
i don't care
what i care is that you as a voter don't
take the bait
don't take the bait let me tell you
something it's too serious right now
i don't care who it is i don't care if
it's desantis
i don't care if it's trump
i don't care if it's somebody else on
the right i don't care if rand paul
steps i don't care who steps up to the
plate
that's the guy that's or girl or woman
or man whatever i also don't care how
you identify whatever the person with
the policies that aren't going to sink
the country that person needs to win
so put your personal
you know maybe you like donald trump's
personality maybe you don't gel with
desantis maybe you're worried about you
know florida and whatever i don't care
put it aside and say to yourself today
one i'm not going to take the media bait
i'm not going to do it they want to
puppeteer me i'm not a puppet i'm not
playing that's number one make that
decision today for yourself because
you're gonna see
i don't know how many columns are gonna
roll out they're gonna just look like
look just like this
okay
that's number one don't take the bait
you're the voter they can say whatever
they want
if you decide that you're not going to
take the bait you're going to say well
whoever it is i'm going to vote for that
person done
you don't need to read these columns you
don't need to engage they don't get the
clicks everybody wins
everybody wins
the other thing i'll say is a message to
these politicians right
these guys need to sit in a room i said
this on pbd podcast they need to sit in
a room
and they need to figure it out
they need to sit doesn't have to be
public they need to say who's going to
run whoever runs great the other person
supports them end of story no drama
there's no time for this right now
we've got the u.s navy watching what
looks like a small child's video on
gender pronouns there is no time to be
like well i like trump a little bit
better than descend oh no i don't know
his personality strikes me as ah oh that
with that one tweet he wrote this is not
the time okay
so get it together it depends on you
it depends on you what you decide to do
with the voting booth that's why i'm
having this conversation not because i
really care
what the feud looks like behind the
scenes but because the media cares and
they're ready to play you and there are
many people out there who are ready and
willing to be played we can't have that
can't have it if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]